A welcome everyone.
Uh,
today we introduce Dr Keidrick golf from,
uh,
Argonne national lab.
Uh,
he's currently a principal scientist and group leader and Argonne national lab
and a senior fellow at a Northwestern university and a previous CTO in ibt
international,
uh,
business technology service.
And he's going to talk about how to define the digital universe.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Thanks you.
Yeah,
thanks.
So this is a title of Nighthawk.
Um,
my name is [inaudible].
So that's a start of where is everybody using this kind of slide,
right?
We talk about for 10 years change how the amount of data change our words,
So for 10 years now,
everybody has cell phones,
have tablet,
they record everything and the upload everything to the cloud,
right?
We go back to the fundamental storage technology.
We like to see a little bit different.
We wango about how we define the data,
how we defined the digital universe.
Then we go back to see how we look at from our perspective what kind of a data
story in technology we need moving forward in the next five to 10 years.
Okay.
So we go back to those are dates,
how the project data,
amount of data from the IDC,
right?
This is a kind of uh,
um,
several years old,
but you know,
the projection is every year we get about a 30,
30%,
uh,
data increase and this is the amount of data that we actually need to store it.
So by 2020 people project about or 40 billion,
um,
is that a byte of data?
So at least until right now,
over the past 10 years,
this trend,
they almost follow in the same way.
Have No,
we have no seen any of the slowdown yet.
Right?
So when we actually look at this,
you know how we define the digital universe,
right?
So when we talk about Dj who worked with Hawk,
how about the amount of data that we actually created?
So we generated and stored and the utilized we can use typically categorized
into four computation for storage and for communications,
right?
So many of talk about this,
we use the basic units are baits to measure that.
And then my mapping this technology and by mapping tools,
the fundamental physics and units like a time,
like a,
you know,
and like a lens,
we defined the beat per second for communication and beat for scoring for the
storage.
Okay,
so now let's look at right at the,
on the Lens how basic unit for the physical world and the older two define the
phaser who were,
did we have someone basically unit and people use?
How about,
so the digital universe,
right?
Historically,
when we talk about the pit,
right?
We saying so basically you'll need for information mostly based on the
definition people post posted and you can actually see the talk about computing
and communication.
So people have really putting those a definition in those word,
but most of the time the Misa storage apart,
right?
This is all right when we talk about this,
a different definition,
but we want to add what does that means when the we including the storage
aspect.
So let's look a little bit right when we add in the storage aspect,
right?
Instead of having beat and mapping where a time.
So or the frequency we have beat per second and bid per square inch or define
anything related to the communication and this storage.
Now as all the data migration to the cloud,
what we found out is we want to add in another uh,
data,
uh,
property definition where we give them the definition called the data time page.
That is the new definition we tried to put for the digital data property so that
he is just about CFA tailored towards the cloud data storage.
So what he's he,
cause I could that definition,
right.
So that's he's the only a formula I'm going to show today,
which is the data temperature formula,
which is shown here,
right?
So the time,
the job of data in here,
we try to define,
we take a 10 times logo bay based on 10 for the Fowler,
assess the frequency and then file that,
assess the frequency hippy guy.
He suggested you find by the number of assassins of divided by the time,
right.
The time most of the people define as a second.
And so you can actually using that.
If we choose the,
the,
the units of time to be one year,
that means that we're adding accounts on here.
Then we can't find our universe or linear response of,
you know,
in the acts acts as a logarithmic off number assessed per second.
The way I access is actually the temperature defined by the degree of G.
Right?
So why are we using this a specific unit and Super Safia formula,
right?
And the next page around them to see that you have somewhere interesting aspect
that kind of actually mapping people's uh,
you know,
understanding of all the physical world.
If you pick up those typical data storage or device,
my hard drive,
right?
The highest RPM hard drive goes up by 1500 Rpm,
uh,
15,000 rpm.
So the average kind of sensor data about 300 times per second when you're using
this formula that's cross funding to the highest,
the time future capability of the,
of the data temperature,
about 100 degree.
That's mapping to our physical word,
a feeling about the heart and the barley.
Tom Pitcher,
mummy.
It talks about the average people using their laptop or you will have daily work
meetings.
You are Sassy or data a few times a day.
And that's again coming back using this data temperature back to about 25
degree,
which he exactly mapping to about a room 10 page or value.
And then people using this to say,
hey,
you know what,
if I try to store my data,
I use maybe once a year family photos,
right tax,
uh,
without those getting back to about zero degree.
Not exactly the freezing zero temperature freezing the,
the in the uh,
freezing the water,
right?
And then you can further extended,
If you look at all of this,
you can see,
hey,
you know,
for this definition and why spy,
you talk about all the data story technology.
You,
you talk about the run,
you can talk about the flash,
he'd talk about Hudd,
you talk about blue and tape.
The actuary can,
oh,
mapping in their spar and all my opinion the same chart.
And you can see exactly each different hardware technology,
how they corresponding to different the capability to handle the input and
output and rewrite of the data.
And when you actually look at those,
the first data digital data I recruited,
um,
you know,
and the store are they in the first generation of hard drive by 1956 if those
data have never been read back,
not corresponding to the time picture of your freezer at home,
that is miners 18 degree.
Right?
So this definition is not only very interesting to mapping to the average of
people's dailies,
a feeling,
but also they have lots of impact.
Right?
So that on the next few minutes I'm going to talk about a little bit about how
does that impact in terms of the data story of technology and then located or
how does that impact and what kind of future technology solution may exist.
Right.
And then at the same time we're also trying to see what's a digital universe.
I have a Lucia,
how does this compare to the physical universe?
And how does this compare to our human society evolution?
Okay.
So before we doing everything like that and the primary reason we give this a
deaf Nasia is by trying to help people to have better definition when the,
to their business,
right?
So one of the reason is this time period,
the definition,
we'll give this a,
a very accurate prediction or a description about how your charges your cloud
service,
right?
So this is where the money goes.
If you look at all the it cloud service provider,
right?
Typically it says,
oh,
I give you a service,
you can have this x amount of the data storage.
And typically a lot of time they sense this x amount of data stories for free.
What the charter is.
It's actually how many gigabyte or terabyte of data you can access.
And those he is to come from the random manner.
So they talk about this Pan Lewis,
which is actually cross funding to oral proportional to your data 10 page.
So every different company using the different terms,
but there is no universal rules by polluting the teacher toll,
um,
data temperature definition,
we can give them a universal definition.
Okay,
so let's look at how does that map to the hardware technology,
right?
This is a wild,
the roadmap from hudd industry.
You can actually see a different technology helping to improve the IRO density.
The project they roadmaps are trying to have the Arrow dance that he kept being
increased.
I had around 30%.
And if you're using that projection compared to the SSD,
you can see solid state memory actually grows at a slightly higher rate.
But when you actually look at as a volume metric density,
right?
The hudd Nando based storage,
a product and the tape there are roughly about the same one,
a metric density.
So why people's,
how they steal from product strategy from price.
That's because the assessor or that the,
the frequency for doing input output is drastically difference.
That's cross bounding tool,
that data temperature difference,
right?
So the actually amount of data is stored is not as important as the compare
tool.
How high the temperature you'll can tolerance in terms of data 10 picture,
right?
So another interesting aspect is if you look at all these data story of
technology particular for example,
Hudd the actor I wrote down said he coverability has slowed down.
So that means now as we try to pack a more data,
we have to build a more hardware,
right?
If you look at the,
over the last 50,
60 years,
this is actually the every single time for the hardiest strife.
You can see as a very beginning and they start to draw.
But seeing,
seeking introduction of the,
you know,
uh,
personal hard drive and all of these,
assess time,
it's plateaued and the flat at our round to Amelie second.
On the other hand,
I wrote down city keeping increase.
So as soon as,
as a area,
seek time become flat,
your time to spend to write her for this four drive start or going up is going
on up homeless or like linearly.
Right?
So this is also means that's,
it takes more time to put a more data on the same drive.
So if you try to assess how those fine lines the same time you realize you are
experience a longer delay,
that means I read your data time Pedro of the drive or snare to drop as you have
more files on there.
So we run the standard simulation.
What we really find is regardless how you assume number of US users,
number one,
assess the the,
ultimately what you'll find is you feel peaker,
any given storage device here.
Then you increase the amount of our assess and then you increase the amount of
data you store.
You just keep packing more and more files there and as you grow,
so the number of files stored on that device,
what you'll find is the average temperature of that drive start to drop.
That means you'll have more files there,
but you have limited bandwidth to do the read write operation.
So on average each fell can be assessed.
That frequency starts to drop.
And if you think about,
you know,
all the story device we ever created and we ever put in surveys as one big
device,
what you can find is over the past 20 years,
the dd or do you only words the amount of data keeping increase as 30% per year
that we stored
the amount,
the files that could be increased about a similar ratio.
But at the band,
the way it's done,
the increased as much.
That's why you also see the monotonic decrease of the whole digital universe.
So you can see this is the same trend.
Therefore the hardiest drive as well as you can use the same analysis for all
different other technologies.
So we've been low cat tower,
um,
different the way,
so using the data,
right?
You can see from the Nike 50th Until 98,
he's primarily all this data using enterprise space,
people only in the larger business kind of for to have that.
Then you get to the PC era and then every family start to using and having their
data story in their own home.
And then after a year or two sound and we start to migrate to cloud,
people start with store more information over the cloud until now,
not family,
don't even store match information in their local a storage device.
So as this change,
what's really happening is there is a fix a number of user for a long time.
But as you migrate to the cloud,
each storage device in the Google server,
you know,
Amazon servers start to have to host the data from many different user.
And this goes very rapidly.
And so what are happened is that's actually creating a different requirement in
terms of the data 10 pitch.
So this,
you know,
a blue [inaudible] is actually a illustrations of the hardest strive kappa
capacity or the last 25 years.
You can actually see the hardiest strive actually increased at about 43% per
year in terms of all capacity until last year.
Okay.
I don't have the new data for this year yet,
but so far found your last year for last 30 years.
It's almost 43% per year.
And you can see,
you know,
as we migrate to the cloud,
the files,
how does doesn't necessarily increased by allowed.
So what's we really see is the number of files on the right hand side.
Also you know the number of houses and go monotonically where's the the,
the,
the drive capacity and the average of data time picture of the drive start to
draw simply because you take a similar amount of time,
you run them selector to read and write data.
But you know,
now you have to go over a lot more files,
right?
This is the,
the case that even 10 years ago,
people here I Google already find out it'd become a problematic because you guys
were all in that,
how do you strive become archive solution rather than actually real time,
sorry solution.
Right?
So this is nothing new,
right?
But when we actually look at this is typically the average data temperature of
our drive and it's a pico temperature value is different.
They can be very by as much as 40 50 degree.
We are located at 40 to 50 degree.
That means you're talking about the five older magnitude,
your difference.
The reason that people can tolerance that is because in reality when we're using
that hard drive for the data storage or using any of those storage device,
what we really have is that we only have very tiny percent hedge or file,
which are heart,
which we need them.
We are frequent assess.
We pay 99% of our money for the data.
We're very infrequently to assess them,
but think about it,
right?
When we put the service,
we charge our customer by the frequency of ourselves.
So that is where are we making the money?
Right?
So in that regard,
when they are putting this into the cloud,
the data storage,
our curtness stories,
Kim is very inefficient because we use a high,
high cost,
more expensive hardware solution store.
Lots of data we almost never use,
right?
But on the other hand,
that's also means because these things that exists,
therefore we can't use the low data temperature capability,
hardware set up to make our complex surveys because it's very hard to predict
which particular piece of information becomes so hard.
And I need them a lot more frequent to assess,
right?
But here is the same when you are actually increased the file sites,
you can actually slow down this data temperature drop to the temperature
comparability drug.
Right?
So as we move forward a little bit,
right when we look at the Hod on,
nice,
I see if this is an average day time period habitability [inaudible] how do you
strive?
We know that I have some people in migration to the cloud.
You'll have more new now,
right?
So human you will have small percentage of data me the high time who trust,
uh,
have high time pitcher but seeing so you'll have more users.
So the,
the number of a frequency and number of assess.
So the will increase.
So once a wound to is the actually the Manders start creeping up as you will
have more user to our sense of same storage device,
but at the same time,
because as you'll capacity increase your data temperature,
comparability drop.
Therefore what you really have seen is the gap between the market demand as well
as your hardware be a billion.
He become larger and larger.
That's gap will be fulfilled about our new technologies.
So in the past 10 years,
solely stay,
drive,
start to oak hill by hand.
How do you strife market is because of this particular reason,
right?
So it's not saying,
oh,
the takeover hottie strife market is to be called how to strive and can no
longer fulfill the new requests from the,
the market,
right?
Because of the migration to the cloud.
So as we can see it,
right?
Five,
10 years later,
right,
we probably have more centralized storage,
right?
Have more user tried to assign a certain set of data.
Now means you need a email,
higher data time period culpability as to the device level.
So that is a word a new emerging technology can potentially come in and start to
take him over some of the hand as this space.
Right?
So
let me skip this.
So now let's look at our little bit,
uh,
um,
different,
uh,
from a different angle to look at this,
right?
If we think of the whole universe is one big or gigantic drive,
We know that's the total amount of data monotonically increase.
So this is the whole digital unit where we only have one drive,
but we have all the possible way to assess the data,
right?
And we know that if we increase the amount of data faster than the band,
the ways that we can actually retrieve the data or to do the radar,
right?
Operation there is a monotonic relationship.
The data temperature,
Keith drama,
right?
You'll have more data.
You created your whole state,
you'll have more requests,
but there's a racial keep withdrawal,
therefore your data temperate,
star drop.
If you compare the answer to the physical world,
you'll see a very similar things right after the big man.
Right now as we did tag our universe,
if we find the all the galaxies starting moving our way faster from us,
right?
We know the universe is expanding.
Now the direct evidence is when we imagined the actually physical time picture
of the universe,
the background radiation temperature starts to drop,
right?
It's straw him over time,
So this are follow the same pass,
right?
There are a lot of similarity between all of this larger scale system,
They look how they satisfy.
Look at our little bit about as we migrate to the cloud,
how the behavior of the cloud service worst as how the human,
so Santiago evolution,
right?
So there is another aspect,
very interesting.
When we have a justice small amount of people,
right?
People create on village,
They,
they leaving ice hole is spouse.
So they tried to build a very small pass.
People work to each other and connect to each other and as a very beginning,
we have the PC,
everybody having their own storage unit.
Then they tried to have a cable connect to each other and then 10 years later,
right?
Then people that society has started quit.
We storm to build town.
Then we start by multifamily house.
People are leaving closer to each other,
more high,
wider role they spilled.
And in the stories space that we try to put the drive to gather,
we tried to put a storage server,
really try to have them to holds,
host the data that have multiple people or tens or hundreds of people.
It says that's underpriced storage server.
Another 10 years later,
you know our teachers who words,
right?
We tried to have the crowd.
When you look at human society,
people concentrate more population density canteen higher you snare to building
a skyscraper,
right?
You'll have all of these multifamily home condos and in the Google and Facebook,
You guys building all of this,
right?
The concentration of dryers,
the density or drives can't even to a much higher level,
right?
So when you compare these kinds of larger scale,
he's,
you see a lot of similarity in between,
right?
So given the of that,
right,
we can learn from each other,
right?
We have lots on the smart way to manage our data center,
but we can also see,
oh,
there might be some problem that's a human society is facing.
Our physical university is facing that kind of mapping to our Dj with worse,
right?
Which is something we need to anticipate those thing happening and finding the
solution right now with a very simple example with how or data archive system on
the hardware side,
right?
Because for the archive,
say some you want the lowest cost solution.
So anything the Kols below the hardiest rife blueray and tape.
Right?
So those have the examples of their data archive season.
So they talk about,
you know,
steel,
we have billion dollar market and you know,
we primarily a host of data,
there's a lower than 10 degrees.
He,
the time degrees roughly about you,
you know,
you an assessor data as once per month or lower frequency.
Okay.
Even Ramey team,
most of the people putting their data in the archive,
Cesa after data,
they're actually expand their hope.
They never need to assassin.
Right?
That's why they tried to drive the lowest cost.
So here as a scene,
the rail,
right?
When you actually look how the state,
you'd still want them to be really reliable.
They kind of keep the data for a long time.
They have low costs for longterm and tennis and the,
hopefully it will be rewriteable.
Well the blue rays,
not truly rewriteable.
So why I've tried to highlight rewriteable Essa important aspect,
right?
So when we look at it from stories prospective,
People talk about,
Oh,
I take this fire offline,
right?
Or worse as I removed the data,
I deleted the data.
Are you raise a data,
I competing in data,
Lisa have all different meaning,
right?
Lots of people using those terms exchange to each other and they don't
differentiate them.
But to,
to me,
to the people who is working on the storage industry,
they have lots of different interpretation,
right?
So if even when we talk about risk data,
there are two different ray,
right?
Lots of times in the cloud space,
You,
you'll,
you'll store your data,
you archive your data when you are actually removed them.
What you'll do is,
oh,
a lot of them have index file,
you know,
compressing a large file.
You remove their index or a secretary to key.
So blueray tape and HDD,
they're all using this master,
right?
And but in rallied here,
That's ps,
all information is still physically residing in that location.
There is,
you know,
no way to change it unless you have other approach to make a modification to it,
right?
So on the other hand,
when you are actually doing the faith of removal of the data,
I mean you're actually right here another information changing the state of the
data.
Um,
hardware.
So that's a real friends until Sunday.
Something else,
right?
So in that case,
the current approach for brewery have lots of limitation because typically they
were right once.
So media and types in rent,
in Siri,
you can do that.
And in Syria can do that many,
many times.
But practical speaking,
you'll have lots of limitation because tape you'll have to physically funny or
library funding or particular tape cutting to your driver honorary,
rewind the following time,
find your old location and take the file out right now after your,
you know,
remove our particular foul,
compressor so far,
putting them back,
right?
So removing one data,
they're taking a long time right now.
How do you strive?
Well,
it's typical,
manageable.
You're talking about a microsecond.
We can make that time,
right?
So when we look at the candidates needs to be done,
is they feasible users,
practical.
While people can say,
Hey,
from hardware perspective,
we are going to clear see the differentiation,
but why we need to do that,
why we are we buy,
we we shouldn't,
you know,
we can skip this,
right?
So let me pick on one example.
Right?
So typically not,
I try to company for example,
I know like a Facebook,
they were very highlight.
How about at the Bruyere base?
A story archive space and a,
I think Amazon using a lot on their tape to do their archive for the glacier
storage,
right?
So these are the two primary,
we are low cost solution.
I think of Google using allow time,
the drive based,
but you guys probably also still using quite a bit on the tape side as well.
So what's really happening?
So you can pair a lot to information to this season,
but by the time for example,
somebody carotene into are really important to event,
the amount will removes 30th and email they scare to in randomly in the cloud.
Right.
What you really see is the steps for writing those information into your
archive.
See some up,
we are similar steps.
It doesn't have a lot of overhead for time and effort and cost,
but when you actually try to feed the equally remove something right search,
you saw the email,
random scattering,
the cloud,
all these three different technology have to go through the completed different
staffs.
And generally speaking,
when you're actually talking about physically removed those information,
assuming only one copy or circus,
how them felt skirting the cloud.
It take her about the two months for actually thinking one dry,
one table archive system to remove them.
They take up all 40 years.
If you ask your mom a hundreds drives running in parallel to do it,
to remove the Blueray Ray and it take about eight hours to remove all of this in
the harddrive archive sees.
Okay,
so those were,
the candle comprise him and he says,
so as we can see,
oh,
you know,
if we want,
if we think I some point that we need to remove unwanted data and that become
important,
then the choice of the data storage technology may make a huge impact.
Right?
So the next question is can we,
or should we write,
be able to actually complete a,
remove the data,
right?
So there are lots of arguments,
On one side it's dominance argument.
Say,
Oh,
you know,
the data is important,
we should never remove them,
right?
And they also say,
you know,
there are lots of field,
it's a federal law required.
You aren't have data for 10 years,
for 30 years.
Those are the two argument on the other side,
you know,
there are a lot of data actually created in way that people privates,
right?
It is something that should be removed,
Or you know,
they were data,
you know,
no data probably will last for,
a hundred million years,
right?
Maybe longer than the,
the,
the human society is uh,
um,
a lifetime,
right?
So the way we were saying at some point in certain type of data may be required
to remove,
right?
So all kinds of thing could happen.
So what's really happening is,
one thing I want to say is in reality,
even for Rhino,
right?
We actually January to a lot more data and we you and throw away a lot of data
without a human,
actually store them.
Those happen a lot in scientific research.
Those happen a lot in even our current like autonomous cars that Google is
doing.
Your sensor can capture a lot more data than you actually collect it,
right?
And he our daily life,
And everybody thinking their kids photo,
but are you sure you actually go back to check every single photo right?
After 10 years or after 20 years?
Are you also doing that?
Right?
Because eventually you're limited by your own time to see,
right?
So you want to see the most important one,
not I racing go wrong,
right?
The second when we look at the face of who process everybody processor date or
how we recognize things,
right on in physical world,
right?
Our eyes,
we opened the amount of data coming in.
It's a much larger set of information than the Harvard brain actually process,
right?
So in reality,
we don't really use to store everything information that's ever exist,
right?
And then the servicing is as we early hockey.
Oh right.
The more data you stored,
the most space you have,
the more files you'll have the data time period or capability to drop.
That means it takes longer time to process them.
You want to make sense of that data is slow you down,
right?
So you order to compensate that,
you'll have to add in a lot more processing power,
adding a lot of cost,
a lot of the,
you know,
um,
new hardware and software,
a new efforts to gather,
right?
Justine,
older to eliminate all this redundancy,
making the sense of the same side of the data,
right?
So from the [inaudible] perspective,
now I drawing a national lab,
they care about the costs,
particularly the energy consumption,
right?
If we store a lot more data and doesn't really use them,
that's a big waste from national perspective.
You know,
it's a bigger way.
So I energy,
right?
So with all of this we say,
Oh,
I sometime people may need to consider how we can identify and remove those
data,
how we can actually physically remove them.
So the answer they no longer causes us to holding them how much they cost.
Right.
Give you one you,
cause I'm Paul this a call is not to chess,
my last name,
right?
This is actually the government accountability office.
They actually check.
So from their report of the assess the Uis,
Carmen,
to actually spend the more than 70% of their it spending maintains those old
legacy system as a readout.
Even like her last year alone,
right?
The we're having some points,
$3 billion less investment or to the new
technology,
but they have to move this farm to maintain the way are old ones,
right?
Those are the information you'll store.
But some of them still important.
But because you will have no way to transfer to a new system,
but some of them may be obsolete,
right?
So when we look at that Facebook,
It's a very young company,
about 10 years old,
right?
Right now they have tried to store all the information people ever uploaded
there,
right?
Some of them may be important,
some of them may be less important,
but what will happen in 10 years later,
right?
What will happen 20 years later,
So those data have to be putting somewhere in their data archive season.
Let's say you're putting the Ray,
right?
Five years later,
you'll find 5% of data may no longer need it.
You have no way physically remove them.
What you do,
you let them sit there 10 years later,
oh,
that'd become 15% right?
So as a time aggregate,
right?
As somewhere realize,
oh,
majority data,
not now that important anymore,
right?
So at some point there is a trigger point.
So if you don't find a solution where you can actually usually replaced,
those are Montay data with the new data,
it's become,
uh,
you know,
drive up all your costs,
right?
So let's make another comparison,
When we look at these things,
we talking about those unwanted data we say in the digital worlds,
right?
That's also cross burning the garbage,
We talk about,
we have a garbage,
we have recyclable,
we have now recycle,
right?
For things you cannot remove.
It's like a non recyclable garbage is see to their forever,
take your space,
polluting your environment and take your resources.
But on them,
profanities include four things you can remove.
Now become a recyclable,
uh,
staff,
right?
And d come host.
You kind of were right with some new information.
So as we migrate to the cloud and now we concentrate a lot more data,
not say it's very similar like a,
remember the human society.
Now we have metropolitan,
right?
This is a CT I used to live,
And growing up there,
now they have 20 million people there,
right?
So you can actually see as a population density growth,
This is the number of s garbage or collecting set surrounding to the CT,
Chelsea and older to maintain the function of the city itself,
right?
So if we think,
you know,
if we can actually,
making all of this to be recyclable,
right?
The number of sites can be reduced significantly,
For the same thing.
If we have our data center right,
we competitor I then he,
if I've unrealized have more amount of data that's actually useful.
Remove those.
You no longer needed data replaced by the use for data,
then the efficiency of the data center as a whole will be improved.
Right?
So there are a few different way to do,
right.
Why will the rare times a to say,
hey,
you know,
data archive,
we replace a hardiest drive the the planter using that to,
to replace the tape or blurry.
At least those are rewriteable,
right?
So of course there are a lot of technical detail.
The people in the hardware side it's working on,
but this is something to get things started,
right?
In reality in the data story in industry there are a lot of ways actually
continue reduce our costs,
but making the rewriteable of this state heart have say some as an option,
right?
So there are some thing that we are currently working on and on those,
the technology we implement,
we said we can lower the drive costs to low enough.
So that's a are appealing to the same field and our people are currently using
tape or blu rays and if you look at it right,
what are this means right?
The full for the Facebook I think they were directing a benefit because all of
the time they are probably a c or the fanciest growth of you know,
useless data,
right?
As a percentage of the data that is stored.
So they don't have to build the additional data center because a lot of this
data sender there,
their information can,
can be removed and then can be replenished in a restore on new information.
And people,
a company like Sega,
they no longer needs for training sites because now they can build an archive,
say some runs,
an unjust Hardee's drive.
Right?
And the same thing for wd is now they have kind of have new product line and for
Amazon,
Google,
for you guys,
you guys are host a larger amount of data if you guys using this.
And you also realize a lot of saving from both of your data center operations,
your data archive system as well as for your service.
Right.
Lot of these different hardware technology,
they can provide this kind of surveys without having to introduce additional
costs.
Right?
So the whole society from our personal actually implementing those things,
there were actually lower your energy cost and lower your energy consumption and
reduce your carbon dioxide emission.
Right?
So this is,
uh,
you know,
from hardware perspective,
we look at how we define the digital universe,
how we store the data and know kind of what's a future prospect.
I think I will stop here.
I think that the saw the bank have slide based.
I say Lisa's as a summary of my talk.
We try to give a standard definition or detail,
a data time feature and then using that data temperatures to study how the
hardware technology.
Okay.
Yeah,
I think that's it.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Okay.
Here's a right now I,
it's a Q and.
A.
Uh,
do you have any questions about the talk?
Sure,
sure.
Is this,
yeah.
One question.
I was normally data,
uh,
even in active and passive data.
So you have redundancies,
you know,
nowadays
not only a single copy of data stores multiple copies.
So do you take that into account in newer,
richer data?
Yes.
So,
so here is the,
you can consider every single file you created.
I think independent when you have multiple data you have on chrome of how this
piece of information.
So each individual piece of information now being an assassin less frequently,
right?
So you can start a,
your keeping one where a hard piece of data,
now you're creating multiple low temperature data,
right?
That's a huge,
exactly the same thing as we talk about as you're creating more copy,
right?
The size of the digital universe expansion,
The temperature drops,
right?
So the way people in the cloud data store in the industry trying to do is,
for example,
when you have a breaking news,
right?
Everybody rushing and tried to search or for some piece of information,
But regardless what kind of,
as ISD or Hudd,
they have very limited bandwidth.
They cannot keep looking for a couple of pieces of information back and forth as
an unlimited bandwidth.
So they just create more and more copies,
right?
But the nice thing for that is typically right after the,
the short pure in time,
we're a hot,
much less than people start searching for yet,
right?
So they removed those redundancy,
If you keep all of this information,
you know,
HDD or SSD,
right?
Your writer with other information that says like you eliminate,
recycle those data,
right?
Recycle those space.
Right?
He eliminated those redundancy.
But what happened is no matter how you to this process,
you always try to keep an archive copy,
right?
The archive copy as a beginning,
it's not a problem.
But if our,
you know,
these are the universe keeps expanding right?
After 10 20 years,
30 years generations,
right?
The aggregate data amount of data become a larger and larger,
So by the time you reach there,
now you have to say,
Oh,
I some point I realized I pay a lot more effort.
Try to keep all of this over the data over the past.
Right?
And then you'll have to make a choice,
right?
There were things that in sync about his two January [inaudible] before,
We don't even have all of this.
The teachers are data that nation people still live fine.
Right?
Of course.
Now it's better.
Right?
But you time the means you'll have unlimited data,
whatever and make you better because,
you know,
no,
I didn't probably most people watching their,
their cell phone more than they actually watching the real life person.
Right.
People go dating instead of talking to each other,
they do texting.
Right.
That's not me know,
be the,
the,
the right thing.
Right.
Yeah.
My kind of second question is,
so normally I sir,
what do you make a,
it's very applicable to kind of services we provide.
Uh,
but uh,
like we as a cloud service provider,
uh,
sometimes the data written,
you know,
like,
uh,
the data criticality or the data retention that took him and comes from the
customers.
Do you have any,
um,
uh,
do you have any opportunities that are bad we can provide this data?
Temperature suggestions to them are,
yes.
So this is actually the kind of interesting part,
right?
Because for example,
you Fi,
you know,
talk to people like you guys or like a Microsoft when there are sales people,
right?
When they sell to their customer about cloud service,
They basically just use,
in our former,
right,
you'll have x amount of terabyte storing in our server,
you'll have this abandoned west,
then you'll pay an amount of money,
right?
So when those people coming to talking to you,
In reality,
the pre,
the premium to alleyways data,
Tammy recoverability,
right?
The character here is,
oh,
we go there,
a log rhythmic.
So you can,
they say,
oh,
we have our few tiers.
Right?
Changing by five degree,
you'll changing by double your price.
Right?
This can be really translated there,
right.
It's just every company probably using very similar formula,
but there were no way to talk to each other to try to standardize them.
Right.
So that is a kind of an interesting aspect.
That's why I tried to use,
there's a formula because I feel like,
oh,
it's very interesting because people who are naughty working in the technology
side now can use that carry correlate to this degree.
It was there,
you know,
daily life.
Right.
By the at the same time when you actually look across serious.
That's exactly the kind of form there.
All this,
the you'll okay.
[inaudible] it's a very interesting perspective to compare this with actually.
For Real.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Yeah.
And just have a follow up question to what she talk about.
All the companies are already using similar concept,
the no standardized yet.
How is the progress of standardizing and the water,
the company's reactions when they,
when you bring up this concept?
So,
um,
good question.
So the standard was a formula now time for them before you're just come saw it
sanctuary in an earlier slide where you can see,
um,
I just,
I'm startled publishing this a few months ago,
started talking to other people.
Um,
it's a very interesting ass an ag because,
uh,
even reality,
right?
Every company,
they,
Justin you tool.
However our formula this,
they show it to their customer,
right?
So I'm practical aspect.
Um,
you know,
if they sing because they can sell to their customer primary,
that's good enough.
Right?
But for the people working on the storage inside particular last couple of years
I started to looking at,
you know,
I used to be working for cigarette,
the harddrive company,
right?
Low Cab and scientific data storage technology.
But I tried to champion outside to look at,
hey,
how are you two different technology in fact interact each other.
So for example,
why as ISD taking over some of the market on HDD or the past few years,
right?
So I tried to say,
hey,
you know,
either some universal relation there,
right then that I wrote as a high,
you know,
people in the IT industry,
they have this and this equivalency,
right?
They're all following the similar trend,
but nobody really tried to put something in there.
So I hope that people will snap into buying this and the soul.
I'm starting to try to press all different data storage company to start using
something like this.
Uh,
last year my first son President does a magnitude recording conference.
It was very interesting because normally only hardrive company go to those
conference.
But I do see people from,
whereas on Facebook and I'll go there and listen to that talk.
So hopefully they was feeling like,
oh this is interesting.
And I think that if we got him more,
um,
how to say,
because I myself is from hardware side,
right?
Funds Star aging.
That's right.
If I got more opportunity to talk to the people in the cloud space,
right?
Or maybe being open compute nodes,
Space lots of this [inaudible] star two,
we'll be able to start to adapt to it.
I definitely think cause that's a very useful because if you look at her in
storage industry,
right,
with our,
all these different technology from paypal blueray how this drives solid state
the run.
And we have lots of emergent technology.
So being around flash and I'm the RM,
you know,
face change,
um,
you know,
three d cross point,
all of this,
right?
But now with one formula,
All of them just following within the same chart,
right?
We talk about our 160 degree,
you'll cover everything included in the data storage technology right now.
Sing,
go outside this boundary right now.
Right?
So this is something make,
make it,
you know,
where we are attractive because people are interesting in the hardware side.
The interest say what kind of new technology or new design or new approach we
can have to take our new market,
right.
Take a market,
current hub,
right.
My starting point in say you're never really argued some technology to take over
the other technology market.
Yeah.
The your or should be or there is a new market,
what is the best technology for that?
Right?
So if you have the same solution,
right.
To me it's the same market now.
Always the lowest cost one way.
Yeah.
But you know,
people have a diversity of needs,
right?
I assume I agree to a cloud actually some of this criteria and become more well
defined.
So that's either for people to look at this evolution.
So that's why you see the,
you know,
uh,
as ISD is booming philosophy years,
right?
But as I,
as I see it taking over,
you know,
high end hardware strive is not because I sic taking them,
it's more expensive is because the demand for that particular crowd service
require high data time here's or capability which hard drive actually creating
more gap.
No today as your,
your capacity increase.
Right.
So you lose the market by yourself is not an other technology taking over.
So that's his word.
You know my standpoint.
Thank you.
Yeah,
thanks.
I think that's it.
Okay.
Thank you for being here and
thanks.